the layers to this reunion between
mother and son are as complex as they
are cruel to hug his mother again this
ukrainian boy had to say goodbye to his
father who was forced to stay back to
fight and have faith that a total
stranger would deliver he and his sister
across the border safely
that's the stranger the boy said
pointing to the woman in yellow
and they cried
[Music]
one mother for the joy of seeing her
kids again the other for what she may
still lose the two adult children she
left behind in ukraine
there is too much agony on ukraine's
border to process it's tragedy on
constant repeat little children still
clutching the trappings of the happy
normal lives they lived only days ago
now confronted with miles to walk along
a muddy border and an uncertain future
my father is military
so he's in kiev he's defending kiev if
they haven't already paid a price for
their freedom they know it could still
come down the road
my message will be very true that it can
happen with you
in every home in europe
because nobody knows
what he
what putin want
and where he will finish it's that
sentiment that's drawn oleg hurt to this
same border crossing a ukrainian who now
lives in germany he didn't have to
return to his homeland but his mother's
sister and extended family are still
there the russians he says must go
but oh the sacrifice he's making
schwager
i've left my wife and three children
behind he says but i'm going because i
can't live with it
that's war an endless series of awful
choices where no one ever wins
least of all the children who are seeing
their families torn apart for reasons
few can explain
microlight global news